or si on prend au début en 2011 pour
l'année des outre-mer c'était juste une
rencontre entre trois départements
d'outre-mer ou trois régions d'outre-mer
on a très vite évoluer parce que la
demande a été grande suffixe céréales se
sont ajoutés haïti le sénégal le congo
cette année et dont on a essayé de faire
en sorte que ce soit plus les
ultramarins qui est les paroles cette
fois ci tu as des rôles yeux ce soit les
caraïbes qui se déplace dans métro ball
ournes dans l'océan indien
c'est le contraire c'est eux qui
viennent jusqu'à ce jusqu ici en
martinique en sachant qu'on était encore
en vie en avant
désolé et que en guyane on a créé le
spectacle de parents ce sera le
spectacle qui va tourner pendant un an
en gros ce spectacle a tourné la
martinique a eu cette chance et surtout
une commune fondamentale qui aura été
cette commune de sainte marie dans la
maison du bénin oui c'était impossible
de passer dans martinique sans faire cet
arrêt
ça fait la troisième fois qu'on fait une
rencontre entre les maîtres du bellay et
les tambours croisés c'est vrai que
c'est pas un atelier de travail au sens
propre c'est plus une rencontre où les
uns un partage avec les autres leur
savoir leur patrimoine leur rythme bien
évidemment
mais l'objectif futur c'est bien la
création d'une académie alors c'est une
académie c'est un peu fort comme terre
mais j'en ai je n'en ai pas trouvé le
meilleur pour l'instant ce serait une
académie qui concernerait des enfants et
les adolescents dans un lieu qui serait
multi culturelle puisque multi
proposition puisqu'il y aura peut-être
un récent et ni multiethnique il va y
avoir des des expositions interactives
face à un projet d'ensemble
mais le point fort sera quand même
l'académie du chant et du tambour pour
les enfants les adolescents parce que je
considère que si en a qui ont besoin
d'être aidés pour l'instant c'est des
adultes sont beaucoup plus responsable
de leur sac